[Music]
[Applause]
uh Let's Make Way for uh Doug Peterson
the Jacksonville Jaguars head coach and
did a wonderful job got into the
postseason got a dramatic win against
the Chargers went into Kansas City and
went toe-to-toe and coached kind enough
to join us what do you feel like you
accomplished this year coach
to accomplish and win the AFC South
uh I think is is uh it's incredible for
this organization hasn't done that you
know in a couple of couple of seasons
um
you know we have a laundry list actually
a first here in Jacksonville that uh
that we we have accomplished and one day
we'll be able to you know share that
with you
um
to go from worst to a year ago to
winning a postseason game you know very
much uh an accomplishment to this
organization and obviously to the
players on the field and
you know to make our make our way into
the divisional round of the postseason
so you know this season overall was a
huge success for us just uh being able
to get Jacksonville kind of back on the
map and and uh you know putting
ourselves kind of laying the foundation
for uh for the future and and something
that we can build on you know going into
23. how important is playoff experience
you have it your team didn't
it's everything you know because I talk
a lot about playing in January and
playing in February here I did starting
in April when I when I took over and and
you know with my first off-season team
meeting we I started sort of you know
using that language that we want to be
playing meaningful football games in the
month of December and January and you
know that's the that's the standard now
uh guys guys expect that and and I think
they now believe that it can be done and
it takes hard work it's not it's not
easy obviously as you know and
um for us to have a couple of playoff
games especially for our quarterback
uh to lead our football team the way he
has all season long uh to get us into
the postseason it's just a great step in
the direction that you know we want to
go
how did your defensive philosophy change
when you realize Mahomes had the high
ankle sprain
you know you think the thing is you you
don't change a whole lot when stuff like
that happens now
um you you still want to execute your
game plan and still uh attack the way
you want to attack in the in the game
um but you know it's just a little more
mindful that hey you know the backup
quarterback is in if if you have to
pressure a little bit more you can uh
maybe get get uh if you can tip some
passes you know whatever you can do at
the line of scripts but really bottom
line is you don't change a whole lot
just because the backup quarterback is
in the game
have you had a high ankle spring
bad way back in college way back my uh
my senior year in college yeah it's been
a long time ago because I'm wondering
about you know Mahomes being ready for
this game coming up this weekend the way
he plays with that kind of injury
it's going to limit him uh number one
um you know it's if he does play uh
it'll be a it'll be a a miracle for him
and the the training staff to get him
ready to go those are those are those
are painful uh those take a while to to
heal uh but I know he'll do everything
in his power to get himself ready and
he'll want to be out there with his
teammates and and he'll uh he'll get
through but it's going to be painful and
sore and it will limit some of the
mobility that he has
how important was having Trevor Lawrence
as your quarterback to taking that job
because we talk about coaches needing
that quarterback we had your quarterback
we weren't quite sure exactly what he
was but we knew he had potential but on
the outside looking in how attractive
was that job because of Trevor yeah you
know what Dan it was very attractive to
me uh having the quarterback piece here
already uh in place you know I hadn't
really studied a lot of Trevor but what
I had studied and watched I was really
impressed and
just a young Young quarterback that I
know and kind of knew at the time that
we could once we got our hands on him we
could get him headed in the right
direction and and Coach him up that way
and
um you know he was just a he was just a
sponge he's been a sponge all season
long and and you saw the progression you
know the course of this season you know
the the mishaps I think early in the
year to really uh solidifying his game
and being one of the top you know top
quarterbacks in the league by the uh by
the end of the year he's Doug Peterson
the Jaguars head coach but having played
the position granted not at the level
that you know Trevor does but how does
that help you you know the game against
the Chargers where you're like hey come
on it's okay patience or what do you say
as somebody who's played the position
before
you know you just you just got to keep a
comb head and and just get him to
believe that we can get the job done and
and you know we just gotta even in the
first half you know if we could find a
way to get a touchdown and we we talked
about this stuff on the sideline we can
find a way to get ourselves in the end
zone before the half ended uh felt like
we get ourselves right back into the
football game and then just continuing
to talk to him like hey it's just going
to be a one play at a time and really
chip away at the uh at the deficit that
we put ourselves in and and um you know
the defense was the same way and and you
know all we needed was some stops
defensively and then offense you know at
halftime we said hey we're gonna have to
score Every Time We Touch the football
and and we were able to do that uh and
and Come Away with that win but it's
just a it's a mindset that hey we've got
to take care of the football uh score
every time we gotta score touchdowns not
field goals and then you know
defensively you got to do your job and
get off the field
do you ever talk to your players about
your playing career
I do I do from time to time
um they probably don't remember some of
the guides that I played with because
they're because they're young but I do I
do share some stories from time to time
okay but what is your career highlight
that you you can say to Trevor hey let
me tell you what I once did
well I've shared a couple things I've
shared a couple things as a backup
quarterback in Green Bay when Brent got
injured uh whether he got knocked out by
concussion or by injury and I had to go
in the football game I've been able to
share some things of that nature I've
also uh my career in Miami you know
being the guy that came off the bench
for Don Shula's you know career uh
Milestone Victory there in Philadelphia
um and then and then being a starter in
Philly you know uh in an environment
that is very tough and and uh just just
going in there and and just kind of
focusing on your job focusing on your
teammates
um how you lead by example uh how you
study how you prepare you know each week
is something and you know that I was
able to share and and uh kind of use
along the way when's the next time you
get together with your players
not till April 17th you know that's the
rule that you you that period of time
you can't now can you have can you talk
to Trevor could you meet him at
Starbucks yeah oh yeah yeah I could I
could talk to all our players that way
you know in a social setting and and uh
just reach out see how they're doing and
making sure they're uh you know staying
staying uh you know uh in shape and
things of that nature but you know you
can't talk football you don't want to
talk X's and O's things of that nature
and uh until April 17th when we get
everybody back
congrats uh that successful season I I
would say I don't know if you go well we
only won nine games or you know what
what is successful to you having won a
Super Bowl but given what you took over
and what you did and how formidable you
were that's pretty damn impressive yeah
I appreciate it you know and it was a
lot of hard work in the off season
laying the foundation with the guys but
you know their their determination you
saw it this season with this team we we
lost five games in the month of October
in fact we lost every game in October
this year and it would have been easy
for us to you know really go in the tank
and and uh and spiral out of control
which I think this organization has done
uh over the course of the last couple of
seasons and our guys didn't do that you
know they stayed the course they stayed
uh they trusted the process that we were
uh you know that we were on and and got
it done and uh so proud of the guys for
doing that AFC South Champs you know
again going from you know from last
place to to Really first place is uh is
pretty incredible it's incredible you
know a feat for the guys have a great
off season coach thank you very much
thank you Dan Doug Peterson Jaguars head
coach
great year